to be honest you know what you realize
that there are
basically easier easier ways to make
money if you really want to
to go for um entrepreneurship and
running a startup is definitely the most
difficult way
to go to basically create wealth
but i think that this is the most
impactful and most
interesting one welcome to 20 minute
leaders
just sit back relax and learn from the
leaders of today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley
in partnership with leumitech sponsored
by hippo insurance
opposed labs touring hillel at stanford
leap and
in media partnership with c-tech welcome
to another episode of 20 minute leaders
i'm honored to be joined today by
michael shaulov the ceo of fireblocks
a secure digital asset infrastructure
company prior to fire blocks he
co-founded lacoon mobile security
which was acquired by checkpoint and was
then appointed the head of products
mobile and cloud security for checkpoint
michael is a serial cyber security
entrepreneur and investor he is also a
recognized industry speaker
delivering talks at rsa conference black
hat and infosec
michael cholov welcome to 20 minute
leaders how are you
i'm good i'm good thanks michael for
having me i'm really excited to have you
your career is just fascinating and and
i can't wait to hear some of the war
stories that
that that we briefly briefly touched
upon before we started here
centering around this this journey and
this early mid-stage journey
of finding product market fit of of
running a business especially i think in
the
cyber security world is going to be
really interesting to hear about about
this experience
a little bit about your background the
ceo and co-founder of lacoon mobile
security previously at 8200 at nice
systems
and sold the company to checkpoint where
you were
heading the products of mobile and cloud
security
quite an interesting feed but also a
phenomenal a phenomenal investor
a seed investor in armis and orca both
of those
very big cyber security names
particularly in the
in the israeli ecosystem but but really
worldwide and and so
today the ceo of fire blocks which we'll
get to as well
but michael if you look back at
everything you've done
even before we go about about rock
climbing
as a startup what what what got you most
excited throughout your career if you
had to look at the
like you know specific events where you
were like wow
like this is what i live for what were
some of those moments
i think it's to build stuff and um
you know i was thinking about it quite a
lot several years ago someone asked me
why you keep doing this right or what
what sort of motivates you
and then i sort of realized that i
actually don't know
right i had to think why i'm sort of
continue
to engage in something that is so hard
and demanding um
and then i just realized that basically
what i enjoy the most
is sort of build things and i think that
this is a very unique um
i think aspect or property of the time
that we are living in that
you know if you basically learn the
engineering computer science uh
the fact that you can basically start
you know
with basically zero resources or very
limited amount of resources you can go
and build things that will be used by
a vast amount of people or you know
communities and essentially transform
and that's just fascinating i mean you
know just to build something that works
is fascinating and then to build
something that is actually being
adopted is you and used is even more
fascinating
i think the commercial and economic
aspect is of it
is also interesting but to be honest
you know what you realize that they're
basically easier
easier ways to make money if you really
want to to go for
um entrepreneurship and running a
startup
is definitely the most difficult way to
go
uh to basically create wealth but
i think that this is the most impactful
and most
interesting one right so talk to me a
little bit about why is it the hardest
way
you we briefly started talking about
this idea
of you know the struggles of finding
product market fit and
and those getting started days i'm
particularly interested to hear about
your experiences from the cyber security
space and finding part of market fit
there especially in in the mobile world
and the worlds that you're coming from
but but what were some of those
struggles like in in your personal
career
so i think that actually to go
way way back right to where my my
um entrepreneurial career started it was
actually it's a funny story it was
actually
i think in a high school it's not a
story that i tell a lot but
um i think when we were like 10th grade
or something you know ninth grade maybe
um i already knew how to sort of program
in php and some basic website it was
sort of 98 99 or something like that
and uh one of my best buddies my
my best friend he came back from uh from
germany
and he basically told us and you know
my friends is that you know that
nargilas or hookahs or whatever they are
being called those days they are
extremely extremely popular in germany
but they cost like tenfold
of what they cost in israel where you
know you can go to the
i i i lived in haifa so you can just go
to darital karma which is sort of the
the jersey market over there and buy it
for you know 60 shekels right and and
and in europe they will cost like 60
euro or 100 euro
um so we actually when we were at ninth
or tenth grade we basically built this
website which was called go to their
gila your
um i think the tagline was uh
uh your the origin for oriental products
or something like that
wow and we were basically um
shipping you know getting orders it was
an e-commerce site in you know 97 or
something like that 98
and we will get orders and we will ship
those products to
um to to to europe for for people
in the united states for people that uh
or buy them
you know we've done an amazing amount of
mistakes
back then there is a reason why this
website doesn't exist today
but also it's sort of interesting to see
how you know
a group of sort of teenagers basically
able to
um to identify i think a market
opportunity and
by the way today it's actually a pretty
big market but a market opportunity that
uh you can execute into
with what back in the day was basically
like you know our pocket money i don't
know we probably invested 100 shekels
into
into that project you know alongside
with a lot of our sweat and tears but
um that was interesting for me but what
you sort of learned through this process
is actually that
the early days of a startup are
so difficult and you know sort of fast
forward to lacoon and you know some of
the experience i had before and some of
the experience i had after
is that in order for someone to
basically
figure out a day one um
some kind of triangulation of a market
that is sort of
untapped that you can really build a
product that has
clear demand and can be really clearly
positioned
and in parallel you can basically pitch
that
to investors and they will actually
get it right and they will be willing to
fund you
for that journey and the third is
actually
and even today to basically find the
talent that will join you
to that journey okay is is a very
difficult task that
um even if you're basically figuring out
the first aspect it's not always trivial
to figure out the second aspect it's not
always figure
trivial to figure out the third aspect
and it sort of requires this
multi-disciplinary um approach and
exp i think it's experience that
basically comes through the years
of you know both being a really good
engineer
you know understand how to tell the
story but also being
i think very realistic in terms of how
do you
read people how do you ask them
questions how do you ask them tough
questions
so they will actually tell you the truth
because most ideas
eventually fail
right and so those asking those for for
those hard truths
going back to your your days as as a ceo
of your previous company today you're
the ceo of another company
how do you trigger those hard truths
what was it
straightforward trivial did you get even
those hard truths
when you needed them i
think that um so i'll actually
sort of give you my personal experience
and unfortunately it was
an experience that i think um
was you think clara was more failures
than you know
successes although eventually people
only count the success right
right um i think that that that actually
even before lacuna i've sort of
tried a few startups and most of those
startups just you know failed and they
went nowhere
and when i started the um before i
started looking we had a different
startup
whether it was called blue ridge we
actually raised a bit of money for it
and we sort of and it was very clear
from the beginning that
something about that idea doesn't click
right we would go
to i.t professionals and you know we'll
pitch them the idea and they'll say well
look you know our direction is like
completely different
although like the idea on the face of it
sounds like a really cool technological
breakthrough
and then i called up a friend of mine i
remember i had this conversation with a
friend of mine his name is aviv
he's also a pretty known entrepreneur uh
he served with me in the army and he
told me you need to read this book
called four steps to epiphany
and that was really the book that sort
of opened my eyes and you know
essentially this is the book that i
always go back to
written by steve black but there is a
very clear path over there
around them how do you basically do
customer validation and market
validation and essentially the process
of
really asking those questions and sort
i think transcribing or or am
understanding the answers that you're
getting right because
inherently people always try to tell you
that
this is a good idea because they feel
uncomfortable to tell you that
it's crap and you should just go pack
your stuff and go home
right there is another book by the way
that another good friend of mine told me
to read his name is adam plotnik who
sold
his company to um to microsoft his
company is colorado
and recently he recommended a different
book that is called the mom's test and
basically the idea over there is that
you know if you ask your mom you tell me
mom hey bob i'm now working
on you know an idea that makes my
you know pc mouse a pop current machine
she will tell you that it's a great idea
because you're
you're her son right and as always
you're you're the genius right
but most likely that it's a pretty dumb
idea right
um and most people you know most people
will not be as
i guess dishonest as your mom or my mom
right
but uh but they will fail this sort of
uncomfortable situation of just telling
someone that
is working really hard that uh his idea
is you know in their eyes is worthless
right
by the way israelis are pretty good in
saying that but i think like you know
when you basically go to other cultures
especially in the united states
and you know people are definitely uh
trying to be
very politically correct and um
and and they're very protective right i
believe this idea even it makes a very
strong appearance in one of malcolm
gladwell's books
outliers where he discusses the israeli
air force and and the culture
differences which which bring on exactly
what you're talking about here
yeah but but you know eventually i think
most um
israeli entrepreneurs and and also um
european entrepreneurs they need to seek
for a big market in most cases
especially in cyber security
the us right now is the biggest market
from at least like you know
a single country so the um relying on
feedback that a local feedback is
actually pretty worthless right you
really need to sort of
cross the oceans now you know going back
to our experience in lacuna really we
really sort of took it to heart
in terms of uh identifying uh um you
know sort of following
the guideline those guidelines and um
well
i don't think we sort of executed
perfectly
for those guidelines in terms of you
know actually some of the mistakes that
we've done
in the early stages was relying on you
know feedback of israeli
csos which was not aligned with the
feedback that we eventually got
in the u.s market and then european
market where they were
much stronger for example privacy
concerns that we were not
really aware of um to continue and
follow that path
um i guess like you know somewhere
around nine months in
when we actually started to get that
feedback in a much clearer
voice from the us market and european
market we had to pivot right so
um pivoting is a pretty i guess painful
process
but as long as you're able to do it
early on and especially if it's based on
true feedback i think it's quite
powerful and i think this is what
basically saved us
in lacun right so maybe the you know one
of the lessons learned over there was
you know the process the the process is
important but also the details around
the process are
important and you know just go to the
market where you
uh where you understand it's a big
market and ask the people there because
you might
have and i've seen it over and over
again right that you actually have sort
of
inconsistency in terms of how a solution
or a product
or a value proposition is being
perceived between you know across
different cultures and across different
markets
right where are you um
to those messages that you receive so
when you were receiving this
you know the differing messages from the
us market than the european market
you when you're coming in and you're you
know you're you're a leader in this
company and you're
basically having to you having to decide
whether to
how do you react to to this new
information that is
practically going to make the last few
months
or very different from the next few
months how do you react to that
it's very tough i think that by the way
it's also much tougher when you're an
engineer
right because when you come from an
engineering background
first of all you're sort of in love with
what was already built right and you you
loved in the
lines of code that were already written
and also you sort of
you know you sort of think well we can
build it you know it will work right so
there is a tendency to basically discard
um the discard the feedback uh
you know in a retrospective i know that
feedback was there at that from day one
but i think we
we sort of decided to you know
just not to to react to that and we
basically
were forced to react to that when we
understood that there was no other
option because
you know at some point i just remem i
remember that that
um we had a meeting with jp morgan
already like you know nine months
earlier they basically told us that it's
not going to work for them
from a privacy concern and then actually
one of my investors back then
reintroduced me to some people over
there and i was like okay
how am i going to pitch them again the
same idea i'm going to
you know i'm going to lose face and now
it's not just me it's just my investor
is going to be there
and i was on a flight i think i was
flying to blackhead or something like
that
and um i had basically you know 11 hours
to think about it
and then i sort of understood that we
need to
change how the product is basically
being implemented so it wasn't actually
pivot usually pivots are basically
business people that was actually sort
of a product pivot which is
you know less common but uh we sort of
changed the architecture that uh
removed a lot of the um issues around
the privacy
and then we pitched it to to jp morgan
they were like oh okay that actually
makes sense right
and and then we knew that yeah we we
sort of hit something that is meaningful
interestingly enough by the way i've
seen that multiple times you know i've
as an investor right i've seen it with
hexadiete they did
a pivot similar pivot on the product
where it you know for example
what you see in cyber security is
actually a lot of those pivots that are
being done not on the business level but
actually on the product level
i've seen this in hexadiete there is a
very famous story in
armies of how they basically initially
focus on physical hardware
and based on this the first you know
meaningful client that they basically
got they just understood that they
cannot implement that and they pivoted
to
a software-based solution and that
basically would brought them to where
where they are if they were
you know still sort of you know heads
down going with their hardware
uh device unlikely that they could have
even scaled to the
revenue and footprint that they have
those days so
it's um it's interesting i think that
you know i i can tell
there's infinite more stories and that
we could be talking now and i'm gaining
inspiration from each of them and i
really want to thank you for coming on
20 minutes go by
way way way too fast and i and i do have
a few questions that i love asking in
the end so michael are you ready for
them
yeah i think so all right wonderful well
we'll start
non-committing and they're they they
seem weird but but but they're a lot of
fun so we'll start off with your
favorite subject in
school and i'm curious i'm curious if
i'll be surprised by this one
yeah so you probably won't be surprised
for the first subject that was my
favorite one which was physics right
but actually my second most favorite
subject was more like around
cinemagraphy right so uh okay movies and
things like that that was uh
my second most favorite subject what was
what is it about cinematography that you
that drew your attention
um i you know i think that
sort of filming and directing um and the
way that
the films are being constructed you know
in terms of that you actually
can basically put the plot and you know
film from different
directions which just gives a whole new
perspective to the story
uh that was like fascinating for me in
terms of how you
you know you construct and structure
those things i love it
okay one of your role models throughout
your life whether it's real or fake
yeah it's a good question i think that
they keep changing
continuously i think that one of the
most
inspirational uh um models right now for
me is
uh bill gates right um sort of tempted
to say ellen bask that's probably like
you know the
the the answer that everybody giving but
i think bill gates is more
interesting probably wouldn't be my role
model like 10 years ago
15 years ago but i think that after
watching their
most recent documentary uh from netflix
uh
i was something very inspiring both in
terms of what he's doing right now
and honestly also in terms of how he
sort of changed through his career
i i completely agree and i think that
you know if i if i look at hopefully
you know the type of impact that i would
like to have on the world i can't
imagine going to sleep
better at night than knowing that i'm
both able to deploy
you know means to to make a difference
but also use the brains
and actual whiteboard i keep getting
inspired by by watching his
you know own blog posts detailing the
sewer system you know from a few years
ago and he was practically
you know in leading a small team of
researchers doing it i thought it was
just
amazing that he's hands in you know
picking up the pen and doing it
and you know the the weirdest question
of all three words that you would use to
describe yourself
yeah it's a good one um i think
you know
you know i think that i that probably
first one is um
fearless um
and the second one is um
you know thoughtful maybe
things um and the third one is actually
contradictory so i think that there are
aspects of me that are very impulsive
okay fearless thoughtful and impulsive i
love it michael thank you
very very much uh please book a time
in your calendar with me so that we can
do a few more episodes because it's just
i i know that there are so many more
stories that i haven't even begun to
extract from you so i really appreciate
you taking the time to do this
uh thank you for the inspiration and for
the honesty about your journey i think
it's just amazing
and then continue making a huge positive
impact we didn't even get to start
talking about your the company that
you're now running and so that'll be
that we'll wait for next time sounds
good thanks michael
thank you take care
you